good evening and welcome to the final
gathering for the 2020 corporate chess
league
four teams will compete for the final
2020 corporate chess league championship
we look to
enhance and expand what we're doing with
the corporate chess league
going on into 2021 so we really
appreciate your participation
if you have other colleagues or those in
your network
that are interested in competing if
you've enjoyed this
please pass along this information to
them we're getting
interest from other states outside of st
louis boston area new york area
and so we have a lot of ideas moving
forward into 2021 i want to say a
special
thank you to those in the st louis
chess club of course we could not put on
this corporate chess league
without them without our hosts without
those that have
organized everything for us and so
transitioning onto this virtual platform
this year
has certainly been a challenge and
that challenge has been met very well so
thank you all for participating
and being engaged we've had 11 teams
50 plus players from across the greater
st louis area
wanting to participate in this league so
we look forward to next year
thank you for being here and good luck
to those who are continuing on
after today
it's the round robin for it all the 2020
st louis corporate chess league
championship
and now your host national master caleb
denby
welcome to the corporate chess league
finals uh this night has been
a year in the making with eight teams
duking out trying to
just earn a spot in tonight's event
four teams have prevailed in that task
those teams are edward jones who had a
phenomenal season
they led the league by far this year i
think doubling
second places score so of course
nice to see them back in the finals i
think they are the undefeated champions
still
we also have worldwide technology who
was
in quite a good position going into the
last regular season event and managed to
maintain
second place i believe we also have
enterprise
in third and bayer in fourth and those
two teams
very very narrowly beat out their
competitors ascension
and merits to earn that spot here
tonight so they had to fight for it they
duked it out in that last regular season
event and they earned their spot
here tonight now we'll see if they are
able to make a count
uh in tonight's event uh and why don't
we take a look at the regulations
for tonight we do have uh a round robin
format as you see on your screen
uh and a little bit different than the
regular season here we are only playing
one game per round but we have three
rounds
rather than two that means uh of course
as a round robin
every team plays every other team uh and
then
if we end up in a tie there are going to
be some playoffs at
7 30 once it's all over
so really exciting stuff to look forward
to here tonight one game per round
everything on the line
for these players and four teams who
definitely all
deserve to be here and now i do have the
the team's rosters here in front of me
and looking at it
it looks like edward jones is going to
be tough to beat
but uh perhaps the team with the most
unique composition uh in their lineup
is enterprise they have by far the
highest rated player in the field
in the form of the mysterious kamikaze
knights
on chess.com and that person that
mystery person's rating is
2207 which is over 150 points higher
than edward jones's board one and on
board two for enterprise they also have
the very respectable chess hulky
with a 1900 rating so they are
very very competitive on those top two
boards
now boards three and four they're
definitely not pushovers they have wades
who is 1500 and sweetman who is around
1500 as well
but that's where uh if it does come down
to it edward jones is going to have to
look
to score some points so perhaps
enterprise
is edward jones's number one competitor
to look out for i think they're
perhaps the only team that could really
beat them head to head on paper
that being said worldwide technology
also with a very formidable lineup
uh mjc a 1950 rate of player on board
one
dv dutch who by the way keep an eye on
dv dutch
that guy watches my classes so if he
starts upsetting everybody he plays
it's no surprise tune in mondays and
wednesdays um
and then last but definitely not least
we do have bayer
in this final event uh perhaps these are
going to be your
underdogs for tonight but i still expect
them to put up a very nice showing here
and perhaps even uh you know throw throw
their hat in the ring here try and get
that first place prize
maybe they will be the ones to dethrone
edward jones and they are definitely
going to be be the team with the first
shot at it they are paired up with
edward jones
in the first round and that leaves
worldwide technology
and enterprise uh with the other
match in round one and if i'm not
mistaken
games should be getting underway in just
a few moments here
there you have your round robin cross
table
but let me type in
some usernames here and yes games are
underway and boy
am i late they've been underway for a
while it looks like we start
our night here with alex kurford against
crasta pj
so alex of course uh now actually board
three for uh for edward jones playing
against cross to pj board 3
for bayer let's also take a look at
knock on wood
uh sorry i have to type these in
manually here tonight it's a lot of work
and i also just typed in his name all
right knock on wood let's take a look
this is
board two for edward jones against now
this is just losing
board two for bayer and yeah why don't
we
start by taking a look at this position
because we are well underway here
let's see how we got here we had our
pretty standard italian game both
players
just fighting for the center in the most
natural developing way possible
and then we have castles knight f6 d3
castles
bishop g5 d6 and h3
okay so we get h6 and a pretty
interesting line here
so uh black plays a really really
important move here
in the form of c6 white was actually
making a pretty devastating threat here
to go knight d5 when all of a sudden
this pin on the knight is going to be
very very relevant
and black structure may even just end up
fractured by captures but c6 does come
just in time
preventing that knight from jumping in
we see knight a4 now
bishop b6 bringing the bishop back from
the threat of capture
but it can't it can and was still
captured
we see a trait of all the minor pieces
now and knight h4 king h7 so
definitely knock on wood is uh with the
favorable position here
why is that well i think bishop b6 here
was gonna be
the the fatal mistake that black made uh
pretty early on
so black was concerned i think that
knight takes c5 would double black's
pawns on the c file
so they tried to go bishop b6 uh oops
with the thought
that after knight takes queen takes the
the structure on the queen side
can be preserved uh with that in mind
though knight takes actually draws the
queen away from the defense of the
knight
so white was able to fracture black's
king's side structure and is now trying
to invade
and does successfully invade with the
queen and the knight a powerful
attacking combo
so queen takes f7 not too many options
here for black
rook g7 means queen takes f6
and this one is is already all but in
the books
for knock on wood with that in mind why
don't we take a look now
at the shawl whose name is hard to type
in so i'll type in eagle eye
two two two zero zero one
[Music]
all right how did i do i did well
alright and let's see how this
board one matchup is going eagle eye
here is playing
for bayer and just has a blue square
for an avatar just a a blue square i
thought i had like his his avatar
highlighted but no
he's just a blue square man all right
and up against this
vishal bardwash who is board one
for edward jones a a pretty competitive
spot i might add
to uh to be holding and what position do
we have here well
we do seem to have another case of a
king's side attack and a slightly
fractured structure so it's a little bit
less obvious
than the last game that we took a look
at but this light squared structure is
actually quite
bad for black with the pawn push to g6
now why is that well generally you see
this structure with a bishop on g7 and
that is called the theon keto bishop
very powerful on the long open diagonal
however when that bishop dies now
there's nothing left
to cover the dark squares and in fact
black has just immediately checkmated in
this position
so vishal taking home an early point
here for edward jones and once again
i must repeat there's only one game per
round in this event tonight so that's it
vishal scores a point on board one
and bayer does not have the chance to uh
to come back at all
and with that that brings us to board
four for these two teams
which is vindy versus fishers of men
so let's take a look here we have vindy
playing for
bayer and fishers of men for edward
jones
and it looks like we have a little bit
of an inner meso here
uh it looks like white attacked black's
knight on f6
but black inserted an inner meso or
in-between move
where before solving the problem of the
knight they
inserted this bishop takes c3 capture uh
and now taking the knight would be
useless in light of bishop takes
pawn when black ends up onto the good so
uh oh this is actually what happened uh
i was going to say
so white would be better off than taking
this bishop back either with the queen
or the pawn
and then the threat to the knight is
renewed but it looks like things went
according to plan here for black
so it looks like white may have won a
piece but actually black captured a
knight
and a pawn with this little bishop
maneuver here so black is a head-on
material also looking good for black
and with that we've done the full rounds
of this edward jones
bayer matchup so why don't we stick with
them
for this round and keep an eye on alex
curford's game
all those other two boards looking very
very good for
uh edward jones so let's see what alex
is up to alex of course
the co-chess league founder and i
believe commissioner is this true i
don't know but he's the founder
he's the guy in charge uh and now he's
got to prove it on the board
and once again though it is looking to
be a very nice position
for edward jones and in this case alex i
think the move g6 may be called for here
trying to remove the defender of this g4
pawn nothing is keeping this guy safe
aside from this queen and g6 would force
the queen away
allowing black to capture on g4 instead
alex chooses this move queen g5 which is
just an attempt
to to simplify things a little bit
now white is still going to have a very
difficult time
defending this pawn on g4 but rather
than do it with tempo
black trades the queens and allows white
this one crucial move
rook takes e4 which does indirectly
defend this pawn
on g4 so with all that in mind black
still has a nice position but perhaps
things aren't as good as they could have
been i think that move g6 would have
been a really nice
opportunity for black here in the
meantime though things are still looking
good
you can bring the second rook into the
game want to be using all the pieces and
alex does just that
and now you can sort of just sit on this
this position here uh let's count the
pawns
looks like one two three four five six
seven black has seven pawns to six
a pawn to the good and a very powerful
minor piece compared to whites
and plenty of targets all over the board
so definitely
uh alex in firm control over this
game uh okay with that
i do want to get to some more games here
so why don't we take a look
at this matchup between worldwide
technology
and enterprise so i'm curious how
enterprises
stellar board one is doing the
mystery man kamikaze knight
let's see how this game is going
and yes looking good for
kamikaze knight which is to be expected
as i said the highest rated player in
this event
and it's not not easy to attain that
title here 2200 on chess.com
is quite the rating and yeah
looking good for kamikaze knight once
again black does seem to be a head
material
and this is quite the unique pawn
structure from white here can't say i've
seen
too many double isolated night pawns
double double isolated night pawns
that's a mouthful
but yes these pawns are doubled stacked
on top of each other
and isolated with no pawns beside them
to
guard them and give them support and
yeah they're both
you know on the night files this is some
beautiful symmetry here
but not so beautiful for white because
these pawns are going to be really
really weak
and not very effective at pushing
forward and trying to become queens
which
is our main purpose for these pawns in
any kind of endgame
in the meantime though things looking a
little bit rough on the king's side this
king is a little bit stuck in this
corner
with this knight bearing down on it but
for the moment
everything uh staying defended white can
recapture this piece on c1
not lost just yet but uh
it's seemingly only a matter of time
before
black is able to break through here yeah
i was considering this move rook takes
f5 i don't know if it actually does
end up working here i think after king
g6 black
is is just going to be winning through
some
some pretty complicated complications as
you know
the name would imply instead we see king
g7
and let me explain why king g6 i think
was a bit better so king g6
keeps an eye on this rook and that
doesn't seem super important right it's
it's defended for the moment
but it does become really important when
you realize white still has to take this
bishop back
and then after rook takes c1 this rook
will be serving two purposes
it needs to take back on c1 and defend
this rook on f5
it cannot do both and so black would be
able to win there
pretty complicated tactics though and
kamikaze knight seems to miss it
and plays king g7 instead which is
perfectly fine
and now we see knight e3 trying to force
the issue with this rook on f1
okay so yes rook check
i think is actually a pretty fatal
mistake here now once again we still
have this issue where this rook is
forced to move under different
circumstances this time
but cannot because this rook on f7 is
hanging so for example
rook takes d1 rook takes d1 is check the
king will move out of the way
and then king takes f7 leaves kamikaze
night with a full
extra rook pretty good pretty good stuff
and how is dv dutch doing
i gave him a shout out at the top of the
hour for watching my classes and it
looks like
that game has actually concluded we're
still waiting on a result there though
on my master spreadsheet here
uh in the meantime oh and no it's
official
dv dutch has fallen to chess hulky so
with that
enterprise i think has secured or all
but secured
two full points in this uh this first
round so far
and by the way i should mention i don't
know if i went over this when we went
over the regulations
board points unlike the regular season
don't actually
matter in this event tonight one more
time board points are not important
what is important is your match score
so if you win the match that's one match
point if you draw the match that's a
half match point if you lose
zero match points and the score in those
matches doesn't matter
aside from who actually comes out on top
so we do see knight a2 by mjc
but now this loses to rook takes f1 when
this guy
is just attacked twice and only defended
once tough
stuff uh and we see knight takes f1 with
the same idea
okay so dv dutch goes down and kamikaze
knight
has won this game as well that means
enterprise just needs a half point on
either of those lower boards
in order to secure the match victory
here so why don't we take a look
at wades see how wades is doing
for enterprise and
looking pretty double edged here looking
pretty double edged
this does seem to be good for for big
daddy jazz which is bad news for
enterprise
bad news for enterprise this b7 pawn is
very very important here
and maybe not for the reason you would
anticipate right
it's important because yes it's trying
to become a queen
but its role is actually simply to
distract the black pieces away from the
king's side here
allowing white to break open this g-file
and just deliver
checkmate right the threat of this pawn
is
stronger than the execution some might
say
some smart chess people um
so yeah we see now that black's major
pieces were drawn away from the
protection of the king
and now this file opens up check to the
king
the white major pieces are now going to
invade and
uh i'll be very surprised if the this
black king manages to
manages to survive this this onslaught
of pieces here so looking good for big
daddy jazz but that being said
wades isn't entirely out of it just yet
if somehow
some way black avoids getting checkmated
yes white is up
quite a few pawns but this d-pawn is
actually surprisingly strong
and surprisingly close to queening so
some practical opportunities do still
remain
in this position although i would be
very very surprised
to see uh to see black surviving
that being said i think black or white
has laid a little bit of a trap here if
you take on h6 with check
you actually get met with rook h4
pinning queen to king
and now though wait a second queen g7
and with this white has essentially
given up on the attack
saying instead that they're going to try
to uh
to i guess queen the pawns or win
without the queen
but hold on black queen's first and then
this is this is crazy this is crazy but
f6
queens now f7 is check
and it will be a question of whether or
not uh white can actually check mate
black this time
right last time we saw the queen and the
rock surrounding the king
no checkmate was found but this time
white is also queening with check
and yes rook g7 and i think big daddy
jazz should come out on top
a little bit more controversy than i was
expecting that d-pawn did come into play
but here looking good for white and big
daddy jazz decides to just pick up the
rook
rather than go for more here although
this is actually now mate in one so
so maybe big daddy jazz will find this
as well
i never in my life thought i would be
saying the words big daddy jazz
so much so often okay
uh with that there's only one game left
to consider
uh and that is board four which was
money ballin versus sweet man but
enterprise has actually won on board
four
so they will be winning this match three
to one uh
also very very importantly uh vishal
bardwash we saw win against eagle eye
but also
knock on wood has defeated his opponent
for edward jones
giving them a two-point lead in their
match against bayer
but according to this apparently on
board four
we had quite the upset here fishers of
men
no sorry this isn't an upset and no
sorry i had everything wrong
okay big daddy jazz is playing for
enterprise not worldwide technology
right
on the spreadsheet things are confusing
don't worry about it
okay so enterprise still does win three
to one just not in the way that i
anticipated
and fishers of men does win for edward
jones
which does secure them the full uh
victory
in the match so just one game left and
that is the game of alex carford
who is still playing here we saw him
with a pretty good position
up upon earlier on and this game has now
developed into a rook end game my
favorite
uh and it does seem to be a good rook
and game
for black now the reason for that isn't
necessarily because black has like an
extra pawn this pawn on b6 is pretty
irrelevant to the position
but black's pawns are a little bit
further advanced than whites
and black's king is also a lot more
active here
so if rick dhak expect rook d3 now or
king c1 i would have preferred rook d3
because he don't really want the king
in the way of its own pawn but that's
okay
and black is simply getting there
getting there first
although i don't really love what what
alex just did playing with a little bit
of fire there
was alex if white were to capture
this pawn on b5 and then managed to
sacrifice the rook for the pawn
then black would have to be content
trying to stop these two pawns with the
rook alone that being said
should still be winning and in the game
alex managed to keep an extra pawn in
reserve
which allows alex to just make a second
queen or
even a third queen depending on how
you're counting uh and
with this that the game will end
okay and across the pj goes down on time
and that concludes our first round
all the games are in the books as i said
uh edward jones scores the full victory
against bayer bringing their score to
one
match point and enterprise who i said
may potentially be the biggest
competitors with
edward jones here tonight also manages
to win their first round
as well so two teams in the lead and two
teams behind
no draws in round one either on any of
the boards or
in any of the matches and that brings us
to
to round two in just a few moments
uh i don't know if we are waiting for an
official time
to start round two i would anticipate
that the games just sort of get underway
once everything is
is organized here
okay i've been given word and that 6 40
was the official time
but they will i i expect they'll start a
little bit
before then uh and by the way
this is the round to look for this might
decide
the entire night here uh round two has
enterprise
up against edward jones this is the big
matchup
that we've all been waiting for ever
since round one just a few moments ago
but enterprise and edward jones both in
the lead here tied for first
and if enterprise manages to pull off uh
the upset of the century
and take out edward jones then they will
find themselves
in in clear first place of course the
same goes vice versa if edward jones
wins this match
then they are going to be in clear first
with two
and needing just a half point in the
last round to secure victory
and at least ensuring that they will
find themselves in any kind of playoff
now i may be wrong on this my memory may
be
a little bit foggy here but i think in
the last round of the regular season
we actually saw this matchup we saw
enterprise v
edward jones and i think enterprise was
fighting to qualify
for this finals and they had to hold
their own against edward jones in order
to achieve that spot
and i believe they did i believe they
tied edward jones
in that regular season match so we'll
see if they can take it a step further
here
and actually go on to win and with that
we do have games underway we're looking
at the starting position here
of big daddy jazz against alex curford i
do want to focus
on this matchup between edward edward
jones and enterprise
because of course this could decide the
entire event
and i wonder will big daddy jazz manage
to make the first move
unclear for the moment unclear uh we
also have this game underway which i
guess we'll start with between dv dutch
and now this is just losing
uh these two players of course not in
our marquee matchup here
and we have an exchange slav dv dutch i
knew it he watches my streams
and this is the opening that i play
myself so queen b3 here is
rather instructive generally in the
exchange slav black has to be a little
bit cautious
about bringing this bishop out too early
right if you don't
develop things on the queen side a
little bit first then
this bishop being here weakens these
light squares ever so slightly
and we see dv dutch appearing to score a
very quick victory now
uh bishop takes b8 bishop d7 uh sorry
bishop b5 pinning the queen on d7
and that's going to be the match black
is just losing the queen and this is
what happens
when you bring the bishop out too early
and lock it outside the pawn chain
you fall victim to some queen b3 stuff
now queen d7 was blacks tried to defend
the b7 pawn
but this just loses to bishop b8 and
bishop b5 great stuff
by dv dutch okay
ah and i understand now why big daddy
jazz was not making a move
we seem to have an audible being called
what are these blue squares i don't
understand but who is the
the 20 to one who is this
i think alex may have accidentally
started a random game
and so we see him resigning this to get
back on track
controversy in the second round my
goodness
so yeah it looks like this game between
big daddy jazz and
alex got aborted by the server perhaps
for big daddy jazz not moving
then i suspect alex clicked the new 10
minute button rather than
the rematch button and things got a
little bit out of hand
but other games are in progress here we
have knock on wood against chess
hulky don't be confused by this 1300
rating chess hulky
1900 not 1300 so
as i said before enterprise ridiculously
strong on those top
two boards so that is where they need to
score their points they need to go
2-0 on these top two boards and then
hope that one of those lower
boards can hold their own against their
their uh
tougher opponents on edward jones
so knock on wood here hoping to score a
point for edward jones and then edward
jones as i said
relying on those lower boards to
actually get the job done
well the top boards may be higher rated
their games don't count for more every
game is equal here
and so what's going on what's going on
well we do have white committing to an
early c5
it looks like in the carro con so
both players have done some things that
i'm not particularly
happy about here in the opening the c5
idea is something that does occur
sometimes in the exchange caro
but a lot of times it's a little bit
rushed and not
always completely ideal with that in
mind though black does have to reply
in a very specific way in order to stay
in the game
black needed to fight back for the dark
squares
whenever you're taking space with pawns
there's always a drawback and that
drawback is
those pawns may become over extended
they leave squares behind they're deep
in
enemy territory and they can become
susceptible to attack
so whenever you see your opponent
pushing this pawn forward
you immediately need to be contesting
this pawn and you can do that in one of
two ways
number one black could immediately just
play b6 here and attack this pawn
uh or two black could play for the idea
of e5
in this case white has very good control
over this square so i would have guessed
that b6 was almost required potentially
even
a5 beforehand to stop b4
but instead black made no attempts to
challenge these pawns
and as such i think white stands quite a
bit better here looking good
for chess hulky looking good
so far
alright with that in mind though we do
see 94
and knock on wood isn't entirely out of
the game just yet
they do have some nice central space
here with this powerful knight
and if white were to capture then after
pawn takes
this knight is actually going to be left
a little bit loose
and we might see the game take a very
interesting development after something
like knight d2 there
when i suspect black would be playing f5
and trying to get things rolling
on the king's side even here i would
expect f5 is black's idea
and this move is going to be very
double-edged it's very very weakening of
the squares around the king
but the further you expand on the king
site
the the better your chances actually are
for going after the opponent's king
as well so definitely a deep and
interesting battle
going on here as i flip over a menu
okay and we do see bishop takes c6 and i
quite like this move
by white uh generally it's
normally bad to to be exchanging the
bishop for the knight sort of unprovoked
normally you wait for your opponent to
try and push it away with something like
a6 before you do this
but after f5 black has firmly
weakened his control over the over the
e5 square
by pushing both pawns forward now this
is a little bit of a hole
so white takes off the knight that was
defending this square
and plants the knight on this nice
looking outpost where it attacks the
weakness
on c6 attacks this bishop on d7
it threatens to jump into the light
scored weakness on g6
and it's just an outstanding piece
overall uh with that in mind
uh black should really get rid of this
knight if if i'm
playing with the black pieces here i'm
playing bishop f6 and i'm i'm capturing
this knight
at the first opportunity given to me but
this doesn't actually
solve all of black's problems right it
might be replaced in
on this square by by a bishop and then
is that really better
than having the knight there i don't
know difficult position here for knock
on wood
really good stuff by chess hulky this
game
uh with that in mind let's jump to board
one of this matchup
which is between kamikaze knight our
rating leader and vishal bardwash who is
around 2000 i believe not actually in
800.
and yeah what is what is with uh tonight
and the geometric looking pawn
structures what is
this is like this is some beautiful
geometry going on here
but uh all in all of course looking very
good
for kamikaze knight why is that well
i'm not a mathematician but i do know
how to count one
two three four versus one two
three four five six sevens
three pawns down is not going to be easy
to overcome
one pawn down sometimes you survive two
pawns down it's already looking rough
and three pawns down there's there's
really not much hope at
all of of surviving the day
uh with that in mind white does still
have some work to do here
you're gonna have to activate the king
uh it's difficult to win this game if
you're not using the king
uh because of course black is playing
with two pieces and you would only be
playing with one
so we do see white bringing the king in
and this is the correct way to do things
with that in mind though white may be
considering
some chances for counter play that
vishal might have by playing king f5 and
trying to come into the e4 square
but i or sorry also trying to attack the
e5 pawn and if f4
then coming to f5 and coming into the e4
square
but i suspect it not nothing is going to
be enough here
for black to save this position let's
keep on rolling and take a look at board
three
where alex carford against big daddy
jazz is finally underway
and do they have the correct colors uh i
hope so
i hope so i wonder though oh and it
seems that they do so i think they had
the wrong colors the first time which is
why
uh their game didn't actually get
underway but now they switched it up
alex is playing the right person and the
game is in progress
beautiful stuff uh with that in mind uh
what is actually happening in the game
is a different question entirely and it
looks like alex
is on the attack as we often see him uh
in these corporate chess league events
alex
i i've seen him play a lot of these
things i i know him for for two things
number one he'll try to checkmate you
number two if that fails he will win on
time
right that is how he has scored so so
many points
for his team uh in this corporate chess
league here this year
uh alex is is one of those guys
who even if he doesn't out rate his
opponent even if he's playing someone of
you know seemingly tougher uh opposition
then uh
he's not afraid to use the clock and he
does so very effectively he's won
numerous games
uh on time that otherwise could have
gone the other way
okay so we saw alex play the move knight
d5
this was a pretty forcing move attacking
the queen and threatening to jump into
f6
with check so black decided it was time
to snap that knight off the board
and play queen c7 attacking h2 so we see
alex push
through now to h3 uh now black on the
move
and it's a little bit tough to come up
with something constructive to do
we see the move a6
i don't understand a6 to be honest um
there are still definitely useful things
that black can be doing
for example this knight is not in the
game this rook could be doing more
this rook i would argue is pretty well
placed defending the f7 pawn
but something like knight f6 or knight
e6 rather i think would have been
called for something like queen to uh to
c6 as well offering a trade of queens
might have been okay
but uh yeah definitely should have been
activating pieces here rather than
wasting time with e6
and now we see our a6 rather now we see
alex pushing through with e4
and again you know i am not a
mathematician but i still know how to
count
and by my count white is again ahead
three pawns
the same as the last time i tried to
count so
looking good for alex uh by the way
kamikaze knight did
end up winning this end game against uh
vishal here
uh and yeah now was the goodest time to
resign as any these pawns are going
nowhere
all these pawns are coming up the board
rather unstoppably
okay that leaves us with one more game
oh
what is this chess hulky goes down
chess hulky goes down what happens
what happened the position looked great
for chess holkey look at this beautiful
knight
oh yeah okay got a little bit
got a little bit buried in some fancy
footwork here this knight g6 move in
knight takes e7
just didn't make any sense at all to me
so remember this position right
remember in this position how i said wow
i'm terrified for black here this knight
is so beautiful attacking all the
weaknesses
in fact i would probably play bishop f6
and try to take the piece off the board
so then let's see what happens well
white actually
spends two full tempe to do just that
gets rid of the powerful knight and
trades it off for this bishop which is
exactly what i think black
should have been trying to do so with
that in mind
the game now takes a drastic turn and we
actually see black get this move e5 if
you remember earlier this is one of
those critical ideas that i said black
had to keep in mind
when playing against the advanced pawn
on c5 and so black now achieves this
and things seem to have taken taken a
turn here for black
good control over the open file the
bishop now activates itself
and that's just a free bishop and a free
rook chess holkey just collapsing
at the end just collapsing knock on wood
getting it done for enterprise
and that is huge that is huge
wait a second with that kamikaze knight
one on board one
uh no sorry knock on wood
what ah i gotta look at the i gotta look
at the spreadsheet who is playing for
what team
okay knock on wood is edward jones okay
with that
with that here knock on wood playing for
edward johns
in the black column but don't be
confused because alex kirford also
playing for edward jones
as is fishers of men but not big daddy
jazz who is playing on enterprise
of course it makes total sense so knock
on wood
wins uh this game for edward jones
which levels the match score at one to
one
uh and means that enterprise is going to
have to score an upset on one of the
lower boards these top two boards were
where they had to get it done
so if they want to tie the match now
they do have to
either win on one of the lower boards or
or tie both those games
that means big daddy jazz here has to
stage a comeback
or does their board 4 who is
moneyballing against fishers of men so
let's take a look at how moneyballin is
doing
let's take a look here
and wow moneyballin is getting it done
okay rook versus knight
two connected past pawns and it looks
like if
if the results go the way that i think
they should here
uh we're gonna have a level match and
it's all gonna come down to round three
and potentially a playoff by the way
though i
i i am filled with anxiety after seeing
this move
white's going to play knight d3 and if
black plays e4
the knight f4 check ends the game now
i'm not saying c5 is wrong
but i'm just saying if white ever wins
this game
it's because black plays e4 in this
position when
you're playing against the knight like
this i highly recommend keep these two
pieces on different colored squares
that way the knight can never fork you
uh right now okay f4
i saw a pawn move and i was getting
nervous but f4 is good enough you have
the square under control
but please for the love of god move one
of these pieces so i
don't have to worry about this anymore
just play like king f5 okay real quick
that works too that works just don't get
forked just don't get forked
okay uh king f5 now and black will be
pushing these pawns forward
uh probably to uh to victory
and yeah with this it's it's gonna come
down to round three
uh we do see knock on wood getting it
done for edward jones with that
upset on board two but here it looks
like moneyballin
uh from out of nowhere is going to be
the hero that enterprise
needs in order to to save this match
yeah f3 and there's just no stopping
these pawns
uh flipping back though alex crawford
does officially get it done it looks
like with a queen sacrifice
that's always fun and checkmate on the
board against big daddy jazz so it
really does
just come down here just to see if
moneyballin can put this game in
the books uh if they can then uh
then it's a level match and we will go
into the final round
with edward jones and enterprise both on
one and a half points
okay i am choosing to believe in
moneyball in here i don't think we need
to stay with this game
uh and yes it is now official white
resigns
and moneyballin is your victor so let's
flip over to the remaining match-ups
uh okay this one looking good for eagle
eye and
and again what is what is the blue what
is the blue
i don't something something has to be
wrong there can't be this many people
with the blue square
or unless there's some like sort of
movement going on that i'm not aware of
okay uh and mjc
is actually winning this one sorry i
have the colors colors flipped there so
mjsc
winning up a queen and does that
conclude the round or do we have one
more
that does conclude the round and
wouldn't you believe it
we have two no we don't have two split
matches i forgot the spreadsheet is
backwards
okay uh enterprise and edward jones
split their match but on the other hand
worldwide technology i believe has done
a clean sweep of bayer here winning all
four games as did edward drones
in the first round so
it all comes down to the final round
here enterprise
will be up against bayer who so far
has unfortunately seemed to be the weak
link of this
uh quadruplet of teams
sorry i was gonna say trio but then
there were four really messed me up
so we'll see if enterprise is able to
get get it done against bayer who has
been having a tough night so far
but with all that in mind edward jones
against worldwide technology
this is going to be really really key uh
worldwide technology
in round one did go down but didn't go
down
easily against enterprise they lost
three to one
but i think some of those games could
have potentially gone either way
so we'll see if edward jones can clutch
it out and defeat worldwide technology
and if enterprise can get the job done
against bayer if they both can
we're going to playoffs we're going to
playoffs i'm excited hopefully you are
as well
yeah beautiful queen sack by alex
alright with that in mind i wonder how
long before
round three gets underway a lot to keep
track of here
i'm just closing some of these extra
boards because i don't need them anymore
so let's take a look at the head to
heads while we wait here uh
like i said i think the close matchup is
going to be edward jones against
worldwide technology we have vishal
bardwash the fearless board one for
edward jones
up against mjc who we just saw at the
end of that last round winning with the
extra queen
and vishal on paper is rated 2050 mjc
rated 1950 so a little bit of a mismatch
but still definitely striking distance
there
uh and actually as as i go down the list
it does look like edward jones is
favored on
all four boards but all four boards are
sort of within
uh you know one to two hundred points of
each other so it should be pretty
interesting to see
if worldwide technology can pull off a
couple upsets and play spoiler here
and by the way don't count them out just
yet if worldwide technology somehow wins
this match against edward jones and
enterprise does not manage to defeat
bayer
you could very well see wwt
as your champions
and here we do see our cross table as i
said edward jones and enterprise
in joint first with one and a half
points after they split round two
and worldwide technology does get the
job done against
bayer and they are in second place now
or sorry third place now with one point
uh with all that in mind you know on
paper
it does look like edward jones should
beat worldwide technology and it does
look like enterprise
should be bare and that means we're
going to see the rematch of
the century in the final round
or in the playoffs which i believe
if my memory is correct we do have uh
the regulations for those which i think
we should probably take a look at now
uh while we wait for games to get games
to get going here
uh we have an equal time armageddon
playoff so it's not going to be a
rematch by everyone on the team
the team captains will each select a
singular member
to play one game for the title uh the
players are going to start
with even time but black will still have
draw odds so a little bit of an unusual
tiebreaker here
and it's actually one that goes against
edward jones and quite heavily favors
enterprise
like i said enterprise is stacked on
those top two boards
and so kamikaze knight will have the
chance to once again defeat
vishal barawaj uh in order to
to win the the entire event for
enterprise that would be very
interesting to see
but i do believe games are now getting
underway so let us
take a look we have knock on wood
against dv dutch
and it looks to be a night orf
is it in fact a night or uh it's a night
or with a strange move order but it's a
night or nonetheless we have the
sozen attack uh
often implemented by fischer sometimes
called the fischer-sozen attack
where white puts this bishop on c4 in
order to
make some early attacks on the king's
side here and we see black playing e6
in an attempt to stunt this bishop lock
it out of the game
and dv dutch playing openings from the
chess openings explain class
like i said this guy he he follows the
classes he knows the stuff
uh and we see an early b5b4 i think in
my class i was recommending some strange
bishop b7 move
but b5 b4 i think is very common
as well so we'll see what white wants to
do with this
piece sitting here on c3 i think
generally they usually drop it back
to e2 but no we see white play the move
knight a4 and wait a second wait a
second have i lost my mind or is the e4
pawn just hanging
is the e4 pawn just hanging here dv
dutch
could be off to to the races here
straight out of the opening
uh in early b5b4 removing the defender
of the e4 pawn black
very well may just may just capture
right here and be a pawn to the good
that being said taking this pawn does
not come without
risk you risk opening up this e file
and your king is sitting on that file by
the way a very common motif
is for white to sacrifice something on
the e6 square
and so if black does decide to capture
this pawn you're going to have to reckon
with the weakness around your king
and you're going to have to struggle a
little bit to get developed
okay on board three we do have alex
against uh wades here once again alex
with the black pieces and it's another
sicilian
uh sorry no it's a french turned
sicilian
okay an early bishop b4 check bishop d2
queen a5
we see this trade and white actually
offers the trade of queens as well
okay there's a strange little balance
there between
the queens i'm not so sure it really
favored either player to leave those
those queens sitting there
for so long but now we do see this
tension relieved by the move knight c3
and the question is can black prove that
these pawns are a little bit
underdefended while they are looking
quite powerful
occupying the center they do lack some
support from behind this pawn only
defended twice and also attacked twice
this pawn only defended once and
attacked once it's very easy to see
how something might go wrong here alex
just castles though we see e5
knight d5 and a capture
capture and bishop e2 okay so i've
talked about doubled pawns before
right in this case though i don't think
they are as bad as you might expect
the reason for that is black is probably
at a later stage
going to play the move d6 and trade off
this pawn for e5
also it is quite difficult to actually
attack these pawns
so while they do appear slightly weak
perhaps
they they aren't really a true weakness
because they can't really be attacked
super easily if i'm playing with black
here i'm definitely considering just
playing the move d6 even as a pawn
sacrifice
to get this bishop into the game start
threatening bishop takes f3
when i can think about attacking this
pawn on d4
yeah and instead alex brings the bishop
out this way but the problem is the
bishop just doesn't have a future here
the d5 pawn is going to stay in the way
and while you do get this bishop off the
back rank i would
much rather have this bishop actively
placed on g4
interesting stuff
interesting stuff
okay oh and hello hello to everyone in
the chat we've got nick here nick weiss
and manny who wants us to restart the
event unfortunately manny
i don't have that power i would i would
do it for you i would do it
okay looks like black is going to uh
contest the c file here with something
like rook a to c8 or gef to c8
alternatively there is still this idea
of d6 and i think
black probably should should be going
for this at at some point reasonably
soon
uh white has made their intentions uh
very clear whoops as i resize the board
they want to go rook c1 double up on the
c file and try to invade
so it's really up to alex how he wants
to continue here
and okay rook fda is played trying to
prepare this idea of d6
but now unfortunately rook c1 is
actually preventing this idea for the
moment
because this knight is just under
defended so i think black is going to
have to contest this file
anyways which means i probably would
have rather done it
would have rather done it first okay a5
i think alex is intending bishop a6
in trying to activate the bishop like
this and again i think
all of these troubles are sort of
self-inflicted here i think if
black was just a little bit more
courageous would have sacrificed this d7
pawn temporarily with d6
immediately then brought the bishop out
to g4 we wouldn't have to be going
through
all this charade of trying to activate
this bishop
trying to play d6 we could have just
done it earlier
so alex actually under a little bit of
pressure here
and that means two players are under a
little bit of pressure
uh it does look like black opted
not to capture this pawn on e4 which
perhaps was a wise decision
we see bishop b7 and now f3 by white
bishop e3 knight c6 knight d4 and
okay we do see we do see pieces falling
now
with a exchange oh sorry in exchange
being hung by black here unfortunate for
dv dutch
i was going to say that actually i think
after bishop b7
and f3 black should be pretty happy
about the result of the opening
and the reason for that is that if this
pawn is on f3
passively defending the pawn on e4 that
means it's not
on f4 heading to f5 which is really the
main plan
for white to activate the bishop here uh
really the only other way to activate
this bishop is by sacrificing it
on on e6 or sacrificing the knight on e6
so
after castles though uh if white was
going to play the sacrifice i think they
would have done it now
and so after bishop b3 knight c6 i think
things are actually looking pretty
decent
for black here the mistake comes with
queen d7 i think the simple move queen
c7
might have been a bit better and then
black can even just start simplifying
some things
uh taking on uh d4 playing bishop c6
bringing a rook to the b file rick to
the c file things would have been good
for black
instead though the rook hangs pieces
come off the board
and it's going to be very very tough for
black to survive this end game
and likely impossible yeah e6 now
falling as well
and knock on wood once again seems to be
getting it done
for edward jones i think he's actually
undefeated on the night but
i could be mistaken there
uh okay let's peek in on the word
one match up then which is between
vishal and mjc
right 3801
and okay this is an interesting position
as as well so both kings feeling a
little bit airy
here looks like vishal went for an early
kingside expansion
and then black pulled a houdini and
castle queenside instead
so white king looking a little bit airy
but the black king is also not looking
particularly happy as well
in particular this activity on the e
file white controlling the z file
dominating it
is going to mean that the black king
always has to be wary of some threats on
the back rank
by the way black's pawn on d5 is also
attacked
but by the way white's pawn on f4
is also hanging so a lot of things
hanging in the balance here
i wouldn't be surprised if this game
gets decided in the next few moves so it
makes sense that mjc
is taking their time here i think bishop
takes f4
is just a perfectly fine way to continue
though okay we do see
f takes on g for first
um and yeah this move is okay it's
it's idea is to activate this rook on f8
but i'm
just not so sure that that now is the
time to to include it
uh i sort of think it it also helps
white somewhat by removing this
pawn from the weak h3 square i'm curious
if black is intending to actually
capture on g5
rather than on f4 with the idea of
activating the rook along the f file
if that is the case then um
then wait no this is just tactics black
is just playing beautiful tactics here
if
pawn takes on g4 then knight takes on
g5 pawn takes on g5 and perhaps rook
takes
f2 is the idea with bishop c5 to follow
i don't know if it actually wins but it
is a funny way to to continue the game
okay instead we just see rook 8 e1
by by white and i do think i can call
this move
officially wrong here it's difficult to
criticize everything without having
calculated
it but rook ade1 is just a little bit
too beside the point
it doesn't really introduce any new
threats into the position
and this position is just too urgent to
be playing improving moves like rook a
to e1
you have to do something on g4 you have
to do something on d5
you have to make an immediate threat
otherwise you're going to get rolled
over
okay we do see knight takes g5 black
does still have this idea of taking on
f2
like i said though it doesn't actually
win material but it does look a little
bit
fancy uh so i imagine f takes g5 is
going to be played i can't imagine what
else
uh maybe white was considering doing
something funny like queen to e8 but
this
move also doesn't even win material
black can play queen c8
or take and take and then play queen c8
so not quite a pure back rank mate here
so black should be doing fine but yeah
vishal
you know taking his time understandably
i think this has to be played though
like what else
what else what else
in the meantime do we see alex kurford
winning
uh we do see alex girford winning by
resignation
so that's a second point for edward
jones
which means they only need a half point
on the remaining boards
in order to secure uh their their
victory here
in the third round and who is going to
be deciding
that well it's going to be this game
between vishal and mjc
and if i'm honest i think i prefer mjc's
position here active rooks i think the
white king is a little bit less safe
than the black king
and hold on white has just played a very
committal move
and is it actually okay
for white i don't think i mean black is
never losing after q8
but is it okay for white maybe vishal is
successfully just getting all the pieces
off the board here and simplifying into
an end game where white won't
won't actually be worse uh okay
so black has two options you can play
queen c8 and keep the rooks on the board
or you could take twice and then play
queen c8 so we do see the immediate
queen c8
keeping rooks on the board and i think i
support this decision the rook on f8 is
very active no reason to remove it
i imagine king takes is the idea here
king takes must be the idea yeah and now
unfortunately uh
this move i might just win the game
bishop c5 rookie 2 means g3
and white regrets leaving this pawn on
the board looking good for mjc
so let's take a look at how things are
shaping up
on board four we have fishers of men
against sweet man and
fishers of men seems to have
an extra rook but
is on the defensive here so it'll come
down to whether or not uh
sweet man can make some magic happen
with uh
with this attack it looks like you can't
unfortunately
there is knight g5 king eight queen
takes g6
but i think after the move king d7 uh
that's where the fun
stops although there's like rook h7
there okay instead we see
queen h7 check and yeah this one
definitely isn't it you needed the extra
attacker in the form of this knight
now after takes king d8 is perfectly
fine
and uh fishers of men will likely secure
the victory here
for edward jones even queen f7
this this works as well and now all of a
sudden it is actually white
who is under threat
yeah simplest is probably just to take
this knight just simplify things you
have a full extra piece
and life is good you don't necessarily
even have to do this though
you can just continue playing chess
moves here this works as well
but i always like to get rid of all my
opponents pieces whenever possible
so a valiant effort by worldwide
technology but it does look as though
edward jones is getting the job done
here which means
we now must turn to enterprise versus
bayer it looks like kamikaze knight
is still playing on board one there and
unfortunately for eagle eye
kamikaze knight does seem to be up a
piece here
and likely just winning the game okay we
also
have moneyballin versus vindy on board
four of that matchup and it looks like
moneyballin who was the hero
of the edward jones matchup for
enterprise is
going down here uh in general i like
to be the side with more queens and that
rule holds true here
having more queens is generally good
these pawns while looking powerful are
just not able to do anything
uh okay so that means
that that's a point for bayer on the
the on the board four so
what's going on in the other boards then
this could get interesting how
is big daddy jazz doing how is big daddy
jazz doing against crosstalk pj
let's take a look and big daddy jazz
wow this game black never got developed
what happened where are all the pawns
what happened this game
what i do see though is cross to pj is
pretty terribly low on the clock and i
think that's something we've
seen before now i think rookie 4 is
probably the accurate way to put a stop
to this game
the point being you drive the king out
to uh
to g6 but then you can
force it away even further with rook e4
to g4 so
without this inclusion white can play
the exact same idea but it just comes a
little bit more slowly
because you don't get the tempo on the
queen while your queen was on c6 to
defend
the rook on e4 all good
okay also there's a rook hanging here my
mind was on checkmate
but uh fair enough big daddy jazz taking
the simple approach
queen e8 check now would be good uh okay
queen to g4 is also fine trading the
queens
uh but we do see now big daddy jazz
winning on
time and wow with that results are
coming in all over the place kamikaze
knight has in fact won
vindi has in fact won fishers of men has
in fact won
and so with that i believe it's official
edward jones
defeats worldwide technology and
actually now all the games are finished
is this true no this game hasn't
finished yet
which is strange because there's a
result on the sheet but um
uh it looks like it it does actually
come down
to this game here and things have
leveled a little bit things have leveled
a little bit uh black used to be a head
a full rook wait
hold on what is this game what is this
game okay no no this is edward jones
versus worldwide technology i was
thinking of uh
i was thinking of a different game i
think but it does look like mjc
is going to be to be winning this one
but unfortunately it doesn't make a
difference in that match as edward jones
won all uh three other games okay
good stuff good stuff
so mjc actually just setting up for some
checkmates here
king c1 is probably the way to stop it
okay knight f3 also
but this is going to be rather sad and
again i would play rook takes e1 here
just get it to the king and pawn end
game i know i can't mess up the king and
pawn end game
with this pawn on g7 it's going to be
easily winning and that is what we see
happen
this is the power of the outside past
pawn white is going to have to divert
the king to go stop this pawn
and in the meantime black will clean up
on this side of the board
and win the game okay with that we have
not determined a winner
of the the corporate chess league edward
jones defeats worldwide technology
three to one and enterprise defeats
bayer
also three to one so what does this mean
this means we're going to a playoff and
i imagine
both teams are going to select their
highest rated player to compete
so that's going to be the shaw bard wash
against kamikaze knight
and kamikaze knight is on a tear i think
he's undefeated
on tonight's yeah three and
oh on tonight and vishal on the other
hand
uh is having a little bit of a rough
night here with two losses and only one
win
maybe we'll see a surprise pick knock on
wood
who i also believe is undefeated on the
night on board two
for edward jones it'll be interesting to
see what they uh
what they pick for this one
uh okay what are the names of the teams
we have edward jones and enterprise
those are your
for the moment co-leaders and a champion
will soon be determined we also have
worldwide technology
and beggar also doing very very well
to qualify for this final four beating
out
four other teams in the regular season
with a very nice performance on that
last
last day of the season to secure their
their qualification spots
but this is where the dream ends for
them they have been
eliminated and we go to a playoff
now i don't know the the word on our
organization skills here
uh so i will wait patiently
to see if one of these games gets
started
hopefully i'll be able to catch it uh
but yeah once again here are our
regulations
and rules for the playoffs uh two teams
have tied
so the team captains will each select
just one member
from their team to play one game for the
title and we will ensure that the the
result
is determined in one game because it is
an armageddon game
and believe it or not we are giving
black full
draw odds despite starting on even time
which at first glance may sound a little
bit crazy but
it sounds a little bit less crazy when i
tell you that literally every game
tonight
has been decisive so draw odds may not
be
the uh you know the huge benefit that we
have traditionally seen it to be
at high level armageddon games so maybe
it's just right to make up
for the lack of the first move
i am waiting with baited breath here
hopefully you guys are
as well so far this has been a pretty
thrilling event a lot of close matches
and that that especially tied match
between enterprise
and edward jones leading to the playoff
you couldn't
have written it any better aside from
putting that round two
uh matchup in round three i guess you
could have written written it better i
just did
but still very exciting stuff
uh and let me take a look see if we've
had any huge upsets i know we've had
a few upsets so far i think knock on
wood
has been the definitely the
the champion board two right three and
oh
kamikaze knight also 3-0 on board one
really good stuff by those two players
and how is alex doing yeah alex is also
3-0 on board three so it's tough to beat
edward jones when they have two
undefeated players though those those
are the two players keeping edward jones
in the fight
knock on wood on board 2 and alex on
board 3 both winning all their games
really getting it done there
okay i've been given word they're still
thinking about it they don't know who to
pick
they don't know what to do how could
they have seen this coming
um so maybe edward jones is having this
exact debate
that i just sort of articulated here
where vishal on paper
is the better player rated 2050 but
knock on wood
is simply on fire tonight 3-0 on board
two
that being said of course vishal it does
have a slightly tougher competition
playing on board one than knock on wood
did on board two
but that being said it's hard to argue
with the results hard to argue with
results in the meantime though
i would be very very surprised to see
enterprise pick anybody aside from
kamikaze knight
that you can see down here right 2200
rating
3-0 on the night tough to argue with
with those numbers here right tough to
argue with those numbers
oh and i see our tournament director
nicholas risco is clicking around
final challenge oh boy we're seeing the
magic happen
live before our eyes he is creating the
challenge
it is kamikaze knights
against
vishal okay vishal has been selected the
highest rated player
board one for edward jones he's been
with them all the way
might as well stick with them now
they're they're putting
they're putting him up for that pk
shootout they believe in him
first on the block here vishal and now
we wait
oh this is john boyer kamikaze knight is
john boyer wow
i didn't know that uh so i've been
calling him a mystery
mystery person this whole time but we
know who it is it's john boyer
and i imagine vishal is is just named
vishal this seems like his real name
okay in the meantime i'm clicking back
over to chess.com here
uh without warning and let us
make sure i'm typing in these names
right
so we can see all the action happen
all right i'm following vishal i think
i'm also following kamikaze knight
so when this game starts it'll pop up
right here live before you rise
boy oh boy i can't wait oh i also forgot
to mention the time control is a little
bit different
we have been working with 10 minute
games and despite having this screen up
like four times now
i never read that the games are five
minutes for the armageddon playoff not
ten minute
so if you've been coming accustomed to
uh this blitz chat i mean this rapid
chess with ten minute
then uh you're gonna have to rethink
everything cause game in
five is this playoff it all comes down
to a single five minute blitz game
okay as i take a drink here who's the
whispering voice give me all the side
information
well he's not really whispering but his
name of course
is ben simon and a wonderful producer
for much of our content
all right just waiting on the players
here to get started
they call this building suspense in the
business we're building suspense here
and yeah we're just gonna stare just
gonna stare
at edward jones and enterprise in bold
white text
two and a half points boy oh boy how
long
can we wait for this blitz game before
we just
we just die from anticipation
oh and i've been told the players are on
break they just can't handle it
they got to do that last minute prep
they got to get their juice boxes
they they gotta get refreshed get ready
for this matchup between vishal and once
again kamikaze knight otherwise known
as john boyer in the corporate world
uh maybe he should start going by by
kamikaze night there as well
be a bit more intimidating you know
climb that corporate ladder
uh with uh with the intimidating
username
but maybe not maybe john boyer is doing
quite well all on his own
uh okay so here
we are looking at the last disaster that
happened to vishal
on the board so this is what he has to
recover from he just lost this rather
nasty game against mjc
so coming off a loss we'll see oh one
minute till the start time i'm being
told but we'll see if you can recover
from this once again
we saw white do this rather crazy king
side attack
and then black sort of just dipped just
bailed and castled queenside
and then this is the game where we saw
the funny tactics with queen e8 check
but queen
c8 put a stop to that and then bishop c5
the key move now that wins the exchange
and went on
to win the match for uh mjc
so difficult games that vishal has been
running into trying to play some
interesting chess it looks like
but in this case sort of backfires
making all these king side weaknesses
and then eventually losing this endgame
as we see here with just kings on the
board
64 moves later 64 squares on the board
couldn't have written it any better i'm
just gonna keep saying that
uh okay this is at least as exciting
as the world chess championship i tend
to agree and it's being decided
in a pretty similar fashion um of course
the 2018
world chess championship also going to a
crazy number of
tie breaks with increasingly quick
time controls uh and yeah
longest minute of my life i just i i
need to know who's winning
i need to know who's gonna win i'm also
like a little bit paranoid that somehow
they're gonna start this game and i'm
not gonna catch it
but uh i think i should i think i should
be able to
i'm so paranoid that i'm gonna unfollow
everybody and then follow
vishal again
there you go now we're only following
vishal
we'll follow john boyer as well the
kamikaze knight
and those are the two players that we're
waiting on here
so as i've been talking up kamikaze
knight is the better player on paper
also the better player in practice here
tonight uh
kamikaze knight has already defeated
vishal once so vishal is going to have
to come back
with something a little bit stronger
in their second game i should mention
though we do know who's going to have
white and black is that accurate do we
know
it okay vishal
has black and draw odds it had something
to do
with the pre-tournament seating uh
edward jones being top seed
uh due to their score in the regular
season i imagine
they got to select or they were just
automatically assigned
draw odds based on that
dm their money is on john that's
a pretty good bet pretty good bet john
has been
on fire here tonight
uh oh and earlier manny asked is this
the saint louis chess club only event
so this season which we are concluding
here tonight of course this is the
finals
uh was local to st louis corporations
but i believe they are looking to expand
so if you're interested at all about
learning more about the league or
interested in potentially joining the
league
i would urge you to go to our website st
louis chessclub.org as
alex kurford mentioned at the top of the
show
and you can find more information there
i believe there's a whole page for the
corporate chess league
and some contact there i believe for
lauren who does a great job uh helping
organize
some of this although that could be out
of date uh maybe it's not lauren anymore
but we do have a page on the website for
it
that much i do know and
yes the minute continues
the minute continues as we await
this final game
well what do you guys want to talk about
let's let's scroll through these scores
one more time here
uh pretty crazy stuff this round so yeah
edward jones starting off strong with
that 4-0 victory
no upsets there and then yeah
big daddy jazz i think has been the
unsung hero of enterprise by the way
big daddy jazz actually clinched them
the victory
in their first matchup against worldwide
technology
and then went on to lose to edward jones
so wasn't the uh the unsung hero there
but then in round three
uh i believe once again big daddy jazz
clinched the victory so
big daddy jazz uh with two out of three
points
for enterprise but actually secured
two of their their match points two of
their two and a half match points so
really good stuff buying big danny jazz
here tonight
uh good stuff good stuff
[Music]
and still awaiting these players to
start the playoff
will we see the famous boyer alekhine
i'm wearing a winter shirt is there also
a summer shirt so yes
i got this shirt by virtue of helping to
commentate
the 2019 winter chess classic
unfortunately
the 2020 classic series was sort of
upended
by the global situation going on but um
yeah hopefully it'll be back sometime in
in 2021 so we we actually have four
classics for four seasons we have winter
summer spring and fall
not in that order so there's the email
development at st louis chessclub.org
please reach out to us if you're
watching this show
and want to get involved nope
boyer doesn't have black pieces ah so we
cannot see the boy or alakine
unless he's playing it with white which
would be rather difficult
all rights
and now we wait
now we wait
so why don't we do some some opening
analysis then
why don't i pull up vishal's page here
and actually we're doing some live
googling here
doing some live googling
where is he at where is he at
ah apparently you can't find him like
that here we'll do some uh
we'll do some other searching we're
gonna do our own prep
we're gonna do our own prep here
i need to find this member
this is how the professionals do their
prep by the way you ever wonder what
fobby is doing
when he goes on those like getaway
vacations to like the bahamas
to do deep prep work this is what this
is what it is
this is what he does so john
has the white pieces let's see how their
previous game
actually went here and they even have
the same colors
okay so we had d4 e6 bishop f4
and it was a london type of game okay
vishal playing normal stuff so far where
did it all go wrong
ah so we actually see this idea that i
talked about what
th that it shakes i love this website
dude
okay c4 and we actually see this idea
that i talked about earlier where
whenever
one side pushes these pawns forward they
do become a little bit susceptible to an
early attack and that's exactly what
john does here b3
a4 and then he manages to break down
those pawns
and that was the advantage that i think
led to the victory here
for john yeah just winning all the puns
so perhaps this c4 mistake is one that
vishal
should be a little bit cautious about
repeating you definitely don't want to
be doing
this c4 stuff too early on
but yeah i imagine we're going to see
something pretty similar here going to
see the london type
london type games yeah this just went
very wrong very very quickly here by the
way black cannot play a6
due to captures when there's a quite
uncomfortable pin happening
along this file all right
all right they're going to start
imminently
and oh
all right um i've just been reminded
that there's a best game award at stake
here so
this game is eligible and i've also been
told that vishal
has returned from the break he's done
the prep work
he's had the teammates around him i'm
sure giving him
all the tips and tricks for for beating
the london we'll see if it pays off
we'll see if he can take down
down uh down john boyer be the hero for
edward jones to retain their title
where can you watch the game on
chess.com great question
uh you need to go to live chess on
chess.com
and then you just need to find one of
the players either vishal
bardwash or kamikaze knight oh this is
the way i do it i just type in slash
follow kame kazi
knight just like that and then you're
following them
then when their game starts it just pops
up right on your screen it's crazy
technology
players are about to start i am being
told
by nick risco
alex says here we go everybody
everybody's ready
we're doing it
can i play blind chess just curious i
can
play some blindfold chess on occasion
rarely when i'm really really feeling
feeling up to it i
try to do a blindfold simul and those
always have mixed results
never done more than i think three
boards of that it all gets very
very fuzzy it's not a fun time for
anybody
oh even alex says he can play blind
chess
interesting to see okay this is not the
game these are two random
well not random this is michelle he's
the right player but
mjc is not the opponent we're looking
for we're looking
for john boyer the kamikaze knight a lot
of vishal fans in the chat a lot of
vishal fans in the chat
john boyer he doesn't need fans he's his
own fan
doesn't need it doesn't need it he just
goes
shows up to the board and executes and
here it is
the game i can't believe it all right
what do we have it's not a london
it's not a london john does not repeat
the london we have a qgd
exchange and boy the players are
lightning fast we have bishop g5 bishop
b7 mainline stuff so far
i would expect bishop d3 to follow
bishop d3 is mainline stuff okay queen
d2 is a very very very strange move and
i don't understand it
at all uh okay yeah why not develop your
pieces
right why not bishop d3 okay bishop g4
is also a bit strange i imagine black is
looking to actually trade off these
bishops here
right this bishop was never doing
anything on g4 aside
from being on route to the g6 square in
order to trade off
okay not a bad idea by black so far
we do actually see knight e2 rather than
knight f3
but i don't know if i'm actually the
biggest fan of this idea here
generally you go to e2 with the knight
when you want to push through with f3
uh with the idea of playing e4 but as
it currently stands i think the light
the dark squares might be a little bit
weak
if you play both f3 and h3 you just
leave all these squares
behind right so we'll see what john
decides to do here in the meantime black
is going to play simply
just develops this knight out to d7 once
again
as a reminder black has draw odds in
this game if a shawl
can draw this game then edward jones
goes home
the victors we have knight bd7
and the queen now adjusts itself to c2 i
wonder if queen d2 is a mouse slip
because queen c2 is the main move in
that position where queen d2 is played
i'm a little curious okay and then we
see rook b1
uh which means likely that john is
looking to play
the the classical plan of the minority
attack right
you have what's called upon majority on
the queen side for black with these
pawns and upon
minority for white with two versus three
so a very common plan in these positions
is to use the pawn minority sort of just
launch them at the pawn majority
and create some weaknesses in general
white is looking to capture on c6
and after takes back on c6 black is left
with what's known as a backwards pawn
which can be attacked
which can be attacked by pieces on the c
file
in the meantime vishal is a trade gamer
all he wants to do
trade pieces knight h5 let's trade
bishops
okay i don't mind it at all by black
here just getting these minor pieces off
the board
and now looking to occupy the critical
e4 square
and yeah this is where some some of
those weaknesses come into play
white would love to play f3 but now the
e3 pawn is just too horribly weak
and yeah knight c5 looks pretty but you
know vishal
occupying the e4 square the more pieces
that get off the board
the the closer in his mind he is to to
securing the the victory for edward
jones with a draw
and wow we actually do see knight takes
e4 that is surprising to me
i think white should have left this
piece on c5
hoped for black to take on c5 when after
b takes c5
we do have that weakness we were looking
for on b7
instead these pieces are traded even
queens come off the board
and now white is looking to still play
the minority attack but
i must say with such limited material on
the board
i'm really not convinced that this
minority attack is going to be enough to
win the game
for example what happens if black puts
this rook on e6
you play b5 i take it and you take it
and then i play like rook a2 or
something like what do you do
i don't know also king f8 king f8 is
perfectly fine here
but i think the mistake that white made
is yes
you do have the better structure after
b5 but
if there's not enough pieces on the
board then you can't really even take
advantage of it
right you can't make use of your better
structure if there's just no pieces left
and we do see a takes and now this move
rookie 6 that i was
briefly mentioning okay pawn takes and i
imagine pawn takes
and yeah we have this exact uh scenario
that i was describing
yes black has the weakness on c6 but
with only two rooks left on the board
yes white can attack it but if black
defends it then that's sort of the end
of the story
right what do you do okay rook c7 i
imagine rook a6 now
is going to be the move and while
black's rooks do look pretty awkward
again it's it's a question of is it
going to be enough here
is it going to be enough i'm not
convinced that it is but i'm not
convinced that it's not either
notably black has unfortunately gotten
into a pretty tricky spot here with the
king
it's sort of stuck in front of the
f-pawn here and
would love to be able to move around but
this active rook on c7
is sort of preventing it so now we see
vishal ready to mark time
ready to mark time interesting to see
how the dynamic changes
in this armageddon format here
previously
you know we had some very exciting games
and now i think vishal
is aiming to just steer the game in a
direction where he knows
he's not going to be able to to you know
blunder or lose
okay now though we do see upon sacrifice
by vashall and this was the danger that
i was talking about
about being trapped in front of this
f-pawn black's pieces simply were
getting to a point where they could no
longer move
and so to break out of that a little bit
we do see vishal playing g5 with the
sacrifice of a pawn
and now black is upon down still has
this weakness on c6
but again in a pure rock end game it's
going to be tough
to tough to say if it's enough for a
victory
by the way white would love to start
pushing this f pawn but
he's probably a little bit wary of
leaving this f
pawn in the dust here or sorry this e
pawn on the dust here and in the
meantime
we see f5 by vishal you know
like i said trading pawns uh
well sorry earlier i said trading pieces
trying to get closer to the draw
but trading pawns is a well-known
strategy
to try and simplify things to the point
where you really can't lose the game
right a rook and one pawn versus a rook
is oftentimes not enough for a victory
especially when the opposing king in
this case the black king
is actively placed as it is here
okay it's all on white here to try to
make something happen
and not only is it all on white to make
something happen but vishal
is ahead on the clock and this is really
really critical like i said
it's a five minute game right not not a
lot of time
for for dowling around king g6 is
important here by the way rook f6
i think white has good chances okay rook
f6
and yeah and as i said i think this
actually increases white's chances
pretty substantially
of winning this game with two rooks on
the board it's really really hard to
make use of the king right it's always
going to get checked around
one of the rooks is always around to
sort of harass it but with only one rook
on the board then the king
can get a bit more active and get and be
a bit more included in
the play so that's exactly what we see
happening here the second that rook got
traded off
here comes white's king and it's going
to be used to help advance
these pawns okay we see
f4 now by white and yeah white's just
trying to win with this f-pawn i don't
know if this is
uh the best way to try to win this end
game honestly
it might be i think just pushing this f
pawn here leaving this e pawn behind
might be the best way to go about it
okay if i'm black i'm playing rook h1
there's a very famous chess player in
history by the name of tarash
entourage had a rule for end games like
these
tarasha's rule is rooks belong behind
past pawns so that's what we see black
doing here
this rook behind the past pawn now why
do rooks belong behind
past pawns well because they can attack
the pawn from behind
and indirectly stop it from pushing too
far forward
uh okay that being said though we do see
white making some pretty substantial
progress
in this position and i think this is now
officially a winning position
the question is going to be is there
enough
time that is the question
that we need to solve here
okay if i'm black i think the best
resistance is to go
with rook f3 here force the pawn forward
and then play rook to uh to g3
what's the point well the point is the
king sorry that's not the best
resistance because this pawn's in
in the way hmm
yeah this might just be busted might
just be busted we see rook hha check but
this is definitely
not not it this is not it
okay rook back to h3 now i assume but
now f7
and the the end is near the end is
definitely near
we see check okay king f8 and then i
imagine actually
king d7 should be played and okay this
is the setup
this is the setup that black needs to go
for king d7 here stays in the game
the trick is you can't let this king out
from in front of this pawn
if the king manages to escape in front
of the pawn
then uh then you've got problems okay
now
okay king e6 i think would have been a
bit better would have been a bit better
we're going to see a queen on the board
we're gonna see a queen on the board
and oof unfortunately i must also
critique
vishal's flagging technique here uh it's
much easier
to try to flag if you have a rook
on the board and your opponent has a
rook and a queen than if you're playing
just against the rook alone
oh but what's this what's this oh no
okay 12 seconds to checkmate 10 seconds
to checkmate king and rook technique i
didn't think we'd get here
i thought i thought john was gonna be
able to take that uh
last pawn and then win with queen and
rook very easily
but instead oh no he's getting
he's getting bumped to the edge five
seconds left
okay the controversy continues
oh 0.3 seconds left
vishal tried to trick him there tried to
trick him with the king f1 hoping for
the king g3 pre-move
but it wasn't enough it wasn't enough a
valiant effort
a very valiant effort there but john
boyer
gets the job done for enterprise and
they are
your 2020 corporate chess league
champions upsetting dethroning
uh edward or sorry edward jones uh
who i think miraculously
is undefeated in match play i think they
remain
undefeated in match play they lost on
the tie break
but in the entire regular season in the
in the finals here they didn't lose a
single match
but they did not win the corporate chess
league
wow incredible stuff enterprise
showing that they are the team to beat
edward jones
wow really incredible playoff there
congratulations to enterprise very
hard-fought matches here tonight and
they they
are your victors like i said to even
secure their place
in these finals they had to hold their
own against edward jones in the last
regular season round where i believe
they they
also tied their match against edward
jones
and that's what they did to get here and
then to actually win it all
they managed to hold their own again and
tie the match as well
so wow really incredible stuff i'm out
of breath
that was that was crazy that was crazy
stuff guys
oh this is definitely this is the game
this is it
the game game of the game of the night
here i have to pick a model game as the
prize and i think this one is definitely
it
uh it shows some some really instructive
stuff
about rook end games i think uh notably
this rook f6 move by by michelle trading
off one set of rooks definitely
really hurt his chances at trying to
hold this draw here
and then the technique by john was
actually quite good to to get that
f-pawn all the way up up the board
but okay all right with that in mind
congratulations
congratulations to john boyer who uh
managed to secure the team victory for
enterprise also secures
the the best game of the night prize uh
and
you know does it all for for enterprise
really exciting stuff
so congratulations to enterprise thank
you to all of the players in tonight's
event thank you
you guys for sticking out and watching
this event with me i had a great time
commentating it thank you to everybody
putting everything together thanks to
alex
uh and there you see best game winner
john
boyer versus vishal bardwash really
incredible stuff here tonight
okay i think with that we are closing
out our show for the night once again
thank you everybody for watching as
always my name is caleb denby
and i'll see you next time
or i will stay on screen
[Music]
[Music]
you